Hello, my fellow sky watchers and truth
seekers. It's the angry astronaut, and
I'm back in the studio because I
literally cannot stay quiet about this
any longer. If you watched my last video
about fireball outbreaks, meteors, UFOs,
or perhaps something tied to Threeey
Atlas, then you already know I've been
tracking one of the strangest, most
relentless waves of bright exploding
objects lighting up the skies all over
this planet. We're talking fireballs
that don't behave like normal meteors,
orbs that hover and maneuver like
nothing natural, and an uptick in
activity that has the American Meteor
Society scrambling. Well, guess what,
folks? It hasn't stopped. Not even
close. In fact, the last few days, the
entire month of April 2026, actually,
have been straight up insane. We've got
more fireball meteor clips pouring in
from everywhere. Plus these glowing orb
UFOs that are definitely not meteors.
They're doing things that rocks simply
cannot do. And the crown jewel of this
latest wave, a spectacular blue green
monster that turned the pre-dawn skies
over Utah into broad daylight yesterday.
We're going deep today. Longer, more
detailed, more evidence, and more
analysis. I'm talking multiple angles on
the Utah event. a full rundown of every
major April fireball I could dig up. The
latest orb sightings that are blowing
minds, historical cases that show
fireball UFOs have happened before, and
then we're tying it all back to the
interstellar elephant in the room three
atlas. I've been theorizing for months
that this thing is no ordinary comet.
What if it's an asteroid ship from
another star system? What if that
massive anti-tail it sprouted was
actually shedding small robot probes or
drones? And what if some of them
malfunctioned and are now crashing into
Earth or even slamming into the moon?
Stick around because by the end of this
video, you're going to be fired up as I
am. And if you're new here, smash that
subscribe button and hit the
notification bell. And let's get into
it.
Good morning, alien enthusiasts, and
welcome to another Angry Alien Bulletin.
One of my favorite lines from Escape
from LA, which was a truly terrible
sequel in many ways, but still
entertaining in its own way, I suppose,
to Escape from New York is the more
things change, the more they stay the
same. So, here I am with a slightly
different face in a different hotel
room, but I'm still the angry astronaut.
and the content is still the same and
that counts for the fireball phenomenon
that's going on right now as well. These
things have been lighting up the skies
all over the world. And even though the
New York Times would have us believe
that this outbreak is over
appear to be because after all, April
isn't even over yet. March was a massive
month for fireball meteors if that's
what you want to call them. Although, as
you're going to see, some of these
things are definitely not meteors. And
the notion was that all of it had come
to a screeching halt in April. But
yesterday in Utah, that turned out not
to be the case at all. An extremely
bright fireball that absolutely lit up
the skies all over the state. Even
people in Wyoming saw it. Quite a
spectacular event. And these sorts of
things have continued to happen all over
the planet. So the question remains,
what's going on here? Granted, I totally
believe that most of these events, or at
least a substantial percentage of them,
are just ordinary meteors. Indeed, we've
even found physical remains of some of
these meteors, but others I'm not quite
so sure about. So, in the course of this
video, we're going to catch you up to
date on what's been going on in April.
The major events that have happened, not
only in terms of fireballs, but also orb
UFOs that in many ways can count as
fireballs, even though they certainly
don't behave like meteors. We're also
going to talk about past events,
fireball outbreaks or major fireball UFO
events of note that took place decades
ago. And we're also going to talk about
what might be causing this, especially a
connection with three Atlas.
So, let's kick things off with the event
that's got everyone talking right now,
the Utah Fireball. Yesterday, April
23rd, 4:49 a.m. Drivers on the Mid
Valley Highway in Twili, Utah, I don't
know how that's pronounced, I'm sorry,
are just going about their early morning
commute. And it all of the sudden this
thing rips across the sky like a blue
green freight train, straight out of a
sci-fi movie. It wasn't just bright, it
was blinding. For a split second, the
entire valley lit up brighter than the
sun coming up. Multiple Ring cameras,
doorbell cams, dash cams, you name it.
We've got footage from several different
angles. And have a look at the color
change. A classic sign of different
materials burning up. But this thing was
huge. Reports flooded into the American
Meteor Society from northern Utah,
southwest Wyoming, and parts of Colorado
and even Nebraska. People reported a
loud sonic boom, windows rattling, and
some even felt the ground shake.
Officials are calling it a lid meteor.
And yeah, the lids were peaking around
April 22nd to the 23rd, but this just
didn't look like an ordinary pebble from
space. They're already organizing
searches for possible meteorites in
eastern Utah. And I'll be watching that
story like a hawk and update you the
second anything turns up. Now, this one
alone would be enough to make a video
about, but it's not even the only big
event this month. Let's zoom out and
look at the full April 2026 picture
because this month has been relentless.
Back on April 7th, a massive daylight
fireball tore across the northeastern
United States seen from New Jersey, New
York, Pennsylvania, Connecticut, and
beyond. Over 260 eyewitness reports
poured in. People were driving, walking
their dogs, sitting in traffic, and
suddenly this thing appeared in broad
daylight, brighter than the sun
according to some witnesses, and leaving
a smoke trail. The AMS logged it as one
of the brighter events of the year so
far. Then just 2 days later, April 9th,
another significant fireball over
Wyoming. Multiple videos and dozens of
reports. Same pattern, bright, fast, and
explosive. Throughout the rest of the
month, we've had additional events
popping off in the Midwest, the West
Coast, and even Europe. The American
Meteor Society's fireball log is
lighting up with multiple events per
week that are getting 20 plus reports
each. Remember what I said in the last
video about the first quarter 2026
surge? The numbers are still climbing.
According to the AMS, the first 3 months
of 2026 saw double the usual number of
bright fireballs. compared to the
long-term average. March was completely
off the charts and April is refusing to
slow down even though the lid shower is
supposed to be winding down.
Okay, so we've caught you up with all of
the fireball events that have been
taking place. The ones that look like
meteors should be meteors, although
frankly I'm not quite so sure about all
of them. Then there have been a number
of other events this month that have
definitely not been meteors.
So here's where the conversation shifts
from, wow, neat meteors to hold up,
something is seriously off. Because
mixed in with all these fireballs, I've
also been tracking a steady stream of
glowing orb UFOs from the last couple of
weeks that break every single rule that
meteors follow. These things are not
streaking. They are not leaving smoke
trails. They are absolutely not burning
up. They hover. They pulse. They change
direction. And sometimes they even seem
to interact with one another or the
environment. First up, the Gulf of
Mexico cruise ship footage from April
16th. Balcony cam catches multiple
glowing orbs popping up out of nowhere,
zigzagging, diving towards the water,
and then shooting back up. They're doing
an ocean ballet that no meteor has ever
done in the history of meteors. Then we
have the highprofile sighting from the
singer Casey Musgraves on April 9th.
She's on a flight, looks out the window,
and sees three glowing orbs trailing her
plane for a full 45 minutes. They change
colors, they form triangle formations,
and they keep pace with a commercial
airliner. She posted about it in real
time. This isn't some random Tik Tok.
This is a celebrity on a plane with
witnesses. And don't forget the recent
Wisconsin and Palm Desert style orbs
that keep showing up in the last week.
Silent, hovering, and pulsing. One pair
caught moving together like they're on a
mission. Meteors don't hover. Meteors
don't change direction mid-flight
without exploding. Meteors don't form
geometric patterns and follow planes.
These orbs are playing by a completely
different set of physics. And the more
we see them mixed in with a fireball
surge, the harder it is to pretend that
they're all just space rocks.
All right, so we've covered everything
that's happening currently. Now, it's
time to go back in time, really back
before I was born, to cover one of the
most famous events, famous UFO sightings
in history. This was also known as
Pennsylvania's Roswell.
And this brings me to an important point
I want to drive home before we go any
deeper. Fireball UFOs have happened
before. This isn't some brand new 2026
phenomenon. History is full of cases
where bright fireballike objects stre
across the sky only for the official
story to fall apart and leave us with
something far more mysterious than just
burning rock. One of the most famous and
still completely unexplained is the
Kexburg UFO incident from December 9th,
1965.
Often called Pennsylvania's Roswell. On
that evening, thousands of people across
at least six US states, Michigan, Ohio,
Pennsylvania, New York, West Virginia,
and Indiana, plus parts of Canada,
watched a brilliant blue orange fireball
streak across the sky. It was so bright
it lit up the twilight like a flare.
Many witnesses reported it changing
direction slightly or slowing down
before it descended. Behavior that
normal meteors simply don't do. Some
even heard a sonic boom. Object
eventually crashed in the woods outside
the tiny town of Kexsburg, Pennsylvania.
Locals described a loud thump that shook
the ground, blue smoke rising from the
trees and intense heat. When people
rushed to the crash site, they found a
large metallic acorn-shaped or
bell-shaped object roughly 3 to four
meters wide and a couple of meters tall.
It had a bronze or copper colored
surface and strange hieroglyphic like
markings raised around a band near the
base. No wings, no rocket nozzles, no
obvious propulsion system. Nothing that
looked like any known aircraft or
satellite of the era. Within hours, the
US military showed up in force. They
cordoned off the entire area, ordered
civilians and even local firefighters
and reporters away. And according to
multiple eyewitness accounts, they
loaded the object onto a flatbed truck
under a tarp and hauled it away under
heavy guard. One local radio reporter
said that his film and recordings were
confiscated on the spot. The official
explanation kept changing. First, they
said that it was a meteor. Then NASA
claimed it was probably debris from a
Soviet satellite, Cosmos 96. Years
later, investigators discovered that all
of NASA's records from the Kexsburg
investigation had mysteriously
disappeared in the 1980s. To this day,
no one has ever produced a single piece
of physical evidence that matches the
official story. Think about that for a
second. A bright fireball that doesn't
act quite right. An anomalous object
recovered under military secrecy,
shifting explanations, and vanished
records. Does that sound familiar? The
Kexsburg case proves that fireball UFO
events have been happening for decades
and the public has never gotten straight
answers. When you see the exact same
pattern repeating right now in 2026,
60 years later, bright fireballs, orbs
that break the rules, military interest,
and the just a meteor line. It makes you
wonder if history is repeating itself or
if something even bigger is still
incoming.
And finally, I continue to maintain that
there may be a connection between what's
going on right now and three eye atlas.
I mean, look at the events that have
been taking place in the solar system.
Certainly, we've seen a number of
intriguing comets, actual comets that
have made their way through the solar
system, and certainly that's noteworthy,
but it shouldn't have caused all of
these meteors or these fireball events,
whatever you want to call them, that
definitely shouldn't have happened
because if it did, if there were a
single comet that caused all of these
things, that means that we should see an
outbreak in a particular region of the
world as the Earth rotates into the
debris path. path of these things then
we should be seeing fireballs entering
the atmosphere from a particular
direction. We're not seeing that. So
what has happened in the solar system
that was different than any other year
in recent history? It's because we had
the first really bright and really
unusual object make its way through the
solar system from outside from an
interstellar point of origin. And that
of course is three eye atlas.
So this is where my ongoing theory comes
in and I'm going to take my time on this
because it deserves a deep dive. Three
Atlas, the third confirmed interstellar
object to visit our solar system, was
discovered in July 2025 by the Atlas
survey telescope network. This thing
came screaming in from the direction of
the constellation Sagittarius. It made
its closest approach to Earth in
December of 2025,
swung through the inner solar system,
and scientists are still arguing about
what the hell it actually is. The most
mind-blowing feature, that massive
anti-tail. Normal comet tails get pushed
away from the sun by solar wind and
radiation pressure. You can actually see
that from this particular animation.
They expected Threeey Atlas to have a
normal commentary tail. And as you can
see, it keeps pointing away from the
sun. But that's actually not what this
thing did. Three Atlas grew a
sunwardpointing anti-tail that sometimes
stretched longer than the Earth Moon
distance, hundreds of thousands of
kilometers. Hubble images captured in
January of 2026 showed tight columnated
jets and wobbling structures that looked
almost engineered. Astronomers like Avi
Lobe were openly saying that this
behavior was unlike anything we've ever
seen from a natural comet or asteroid.
The particles in that anti-tail were
unusually large, big enough to shrug off
the solar wind instead of being blown
backward like every other comet we've
studied. And I've been saying this for
months on this channel. What if threeey
Atlas isn't just a comet or asteroid?
What if it's an interstellar asteroid
ship? Some kind of an artificial probe
or vessel sent from another star system?
And what if that massive anti-tail
wasn't dust, but thousands of small
robot asteroid ships or drones being
deployed? Some of them malfunctioned,
broke off course, and are now entering
our atmosphere as these fireballs are
operating as the glowing orbs that we
keep filming. Think about the timeline.
Three Atlas passes through in late 2025,
sheds this anomalous material, and boom,
right at the start of 2026, we get the
massive fireball surge that AMS is still
documenting. April is continuing the
trend. The numbers line up too perfectly
to be pure coincidence. And here's the
part that really makes the hair on the
back of my neck stand up. NASA's Aremis
2 mission in early April 2026.
The astronauts looping around the moon's
far side reported seeing multiple rapid
micrometeoroid
impact flashes lighting up the lunar
surface in real time. Four to six bright
flashes during one of their orbits. They
were literally watching stuff slamming
into the moon right in front of their
eyes. And guess where the moon was
positioned at that exact moment? Right
in the constellation of Sagittarius, the
exact direction that three eye atlas
came from. Coincidence? Or are we
watching the aftermath of the same wave
of material or probes that originated
from three eye atlas hitting both Earth
and our natural satellite, the moon was
in perfect alignment to be in the path
of anything still traveling along that
Sagittarius trajectory. Now, I'm not
sitting here claiming that every single
fireball is alien tech. I'm not saying
we have proof positive. But when you
stack up the interstellar visitor with
the weird anti-tail full of large
particles that don't behave like normal
dust, the perfect timeline match with
the 2026 fireball outbreak, the orbs
that clearly aren't meteors, the
historical precedent like Kexsburg, and
then the moon getting peppered while
sitting right in the line of fire. You
would have to be willfully ignoring the
data to say nothing to see here. This is
exactly why I do this channel. The
official narrative is always just
meteors move along, but the anomalies
keep piling up and the sky is literally
screaming at us that something bigger is
happening. Okay, so let's bring it back
to you guys because this is a community
effort. Have you seen a fireball or an
orb in the last 2 weeks? Drop your
location, the exact date and time, and a
description in the comments. If you
caught it on video, dash cam, ring cam,
phone, whatever, send it my way through
the channel email, it's in the
description, or on Discord. I might
feature your footage in the next update.
We're tracking this outbreak live. And
the more eyes we have on the sky, the
better. And if you're still watching
this this far into the video, you're the
real ones. Thank you. If you haven't
already, smash that like button. It
really helps the channel and subscribe
if you want to stay on top of every new
development in this story. And also,
please check the description for various
ways to support this content. And by the
way, that three eye Atlas shirt that I
was wearing, that's going away at the
end of this month because we're closing
the merch store and we're probably going
to keep it closed for a few weeks as we
come up with some new items. So, check
the description if you want to take
advantage of that. Thanks again for
watching and until next time, stay angry
about space.